[Musique]
pour le moment on va se revoir un petit
toc toc toc pour un peu du toc toc toc
c'était ça regarde et on va faire un toc
toc toc spéciale chansons de johnny je
peux frapper
elle m'a dit toc toc toc est une vraie
qui a eu chaud ken issa kane qui la cgil
bachil gilles qui gilles verdez j'ai
rien trouvé
voilà et bien aujourd'hui on s'est dit
qu'on allait refaire un toc toc toc
hélas cette attention toute spéciale
baba vous pouvez envoyer si vous voulez
attention toc toc toc c'est parti on est
là au pied la ba ba ba ba qui bat yoyo
[Rires]
anniversaire tombera ce beau bébé
attention nos ipod touch book
je reconnais ça tabasse ac n'aura hélas
remettre kpatcha tous qui dit si tu es
là c'est baba bâ qui d'abba ba ba ba ba
ba da da da da vous m'aider attention
dites nous quel est le meilleur
toc toc toc pour l'instant entre
jean-luc enora et avec tout le monde
pourra parler de la coupe après fait
partie non mais on en a déjà parlé
merci à dosso qui est là c'est mama mama
qui les vagues bazarder aller balader
elle est basée à damas
c'est notre anniversaire l'anniversaire
de téléspectateurs soit une version cm
attention c'est parti et on se calme un
soir j'ai pas qui c'est mais ça va se
calmer
je crois que c'est là benhaim gentil
reconnu rire et la sai baba bac et baba
tout est neuf et tout est seul continent
son grillage huawei baba et elle a fait
premier degré au fait est ce qu a été
une soirée douce voire un peu sexuelle
c'est excitant
les partis et la sai baba on t'a reconnu
mais la gym c'est qui ça c'est bien bâti
ben merde vont suivre
alors on la refait et la bombe et la
n164 an dernier mais là il arrive à se
soulever plus dans la radio c'est sur le
sol at il dit qui est la vente attaque
oui c'est qui est ma ba on l'a en tout
cas le web à baky ou feb about est où
est brassée rentrée il assurait déjà
tout le monde sait qui c'est baba est
bon je pense ça suffit d à bas coût le
ba ba ba balle basque et où et oui on
danse on danse on danse bal masqué dans
la tristesse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien vu leur compte en particulier
la ceiba bas de la ceinture en bois sont
là bas c'est baba bâ qui bat bbm
[Rires]
habib allah
[Musique]
ne pas dissimuler watch il est pour
l'instant mathieu pas mal à merci ah oui
pas mal à adresser au vrai plaisir est
là qu'est la sema marco les bacs et
babacar
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le tabac tue leur fait d'accord charpy
tu leur fais leur fait mais laurent
terre on va voir s'il me retape attend
sur ses partitions je veux dire ah oui
et là c'est papa à baky ba baca et l'eau
et l'autre l autre est probable et son
interprétation
attention la prochaine ces parties qui
qui est là et baba assemblée mais là il
on vous rappelle non s'il vous plaît
j'ai rien dit est ce que tu veux non je
veux chanter le s'il vous plaît qu'est
ce que tu veux tu vas chanter je veux
chanter quoi
bah alors ce que je propose pas rester
derrière la porte pour l'instant il
sourit
merci d'accueillir valérie bénaïm
qu'elle a c'est baba bâ qui on va sortir
bon sens pour eux
webb rappelle à m mais l' hymne vous
travaillez tout ça non mais travailler
tout ça j'en ai rien appris
vous travaillez tout ça on revient dans
un instant non mais tu me fait passer
pour un coup de fil je vois ce que tu en
train de faire la médaille mais j'allais
je ne vois pas ta rien du tout mais là
je retiens tu entends tu aurais tu vas
rien te dire du tout clair tu te
concentres et on se remet à dans
quelques miettes à ses livres excusez
moi mais pas la vallée mais là il va
arriver dans un instant elle reste la
province tant les autres voilà les
médailles malgré cela elle sera sont
autochtones tout seul je veux que tout
moi j'aurais vraiment que tout le monde
quitte le hall allez-y elle va sortir
elle sera tout seul pour 60 ans tu ne
connais tout le monde s'emballe n'était
pas des dégénérés et vous allez assister
à un moment très très faim de télévision
ce sera dans un instant dans tout sur
mon poste on arrive que tu devais voter
les cherry à valérie benaïm quête encore
dehors on verra son toc toc toc tout
seul
d'accord elle va le faire tout seul dans
le hall je veux vraiment que hall soit
vide totalement
est ce que le hall évident s'il vous
plaît je veux que ce soit la séquence la
plus triste on ne veut pas de lui la
personne l'a quand même le monsieur la
tour et sortez tout le monde vous me
sortez tout le monde même le wiki oui
mais est mu
jeumont personnes non lui-même même
personne
on ne veut perdre elle n'est pas parce
que je cherchais le allait passer
rzeszow mais sans déconner alors on ne
veut personne dans le hall et celle il y
aura le toc toc toc de balle et les
médailles dans un instant belaïd
d'affaires sont aptes à tout seul est ce
que vous m'entendez valérie moi je vous
entends très bien voyage peut revoir le
haut est ce qu'on peut en faire un point
sur le rôle s'il vous plaît les cadres a
apparemment il ya john deere de fautes
des deux personnes je veux vraiment et
veste ou pas avoir un plan s'il vous
plaît plus large parce que là c'est pas
beau ça marche moins bien comme ça
d'accord donc je veux un plan plus large
merci jean jacques amsellem voilà de
faire un problème si je dois faire aussi
la réalisation des missions
ça veut dire moi un voilà c'est beaucoup
plus drôle comme ça merci jean jacques
avait chéri on va faire le toc toc toc
de valérie benaïm alors on n'entend pas
d'ici maintenant que toc toc alors
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est qu'il puisse y avoir personne
bordel alors oui alors allez-y total
cash
bon je le sens pas on revient de thaler
caisse canon mais non on est bien mais
un tueur vient quand qui déconne quoi
mais on fait monter la sauce
mais arrête de faire remonter quoi que
ce soit mais on revient aux romains qui
va jamais revenir je te connais rébéna
yves vous me connaissez n'a justement
c'est un connard
[Applaudissements]
on va faire plus et la porte en elle une
chaise données du trésor à s'asseoir à
la naspe allegri belle parce qu'elle est
toujours là quand même aller mais là il
va alors on va le faire alors il ya un
cas je râle à [ __ ] c'est qui ça avant
dessus c'est hugo cechosz un nom bien
connu que je vois rien et non mais tu te
fous de ma gueule hanouna ah oui le
connais pas
le plr énervé le gars quand la mer se
louer le pot de colle avec hidden chaîne
plateau oui vous êtes qui madame non
mais tu te fous de ma gueule
oui oui c'est bien ce que je m'en fous
ça arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a tendu la vallée
et la libye sécurisée d'après la
sécurité
regarde soit la nano d'homère si mokhtar
héros mais là derrière la porte mon
chéri aller cooper s'est tout de suite
reste à côté reste à côté d' al mokhtar
ayari voulait rentrer bah oui bon alors
c'est déjà le dr d'accord nul allez on
revient tout à l'heure
attention on va voir est-ce que benhaim
rentrer maintenant moi je pense que oui
oui je pense que vous benhaim bella et
oui c'est banal c'est oui à 40% vous dis
non non non mais sérieux pour la salle
d'un carrosse d'or moi mais c'est pas
très gentil bien
ben c'est pas moi qui décide c'est les
téléspectateurs pour l'instant ni l'on
vous plaît faites ma rentrée alors
nalanda le sondage regarde et attend sur
le sondage ben haim bah oui oui ça
tourne et c'est bon bon bah là faites le
vite avant que ça retourne dans l'autre
côté attaque qui est là c'est à la ba ba
qui n'est pas l'image est pas imaginable
[Rires]
je ne fais pas du vélo et trois ans un
autre je suis là on a entendu way a
étonné nous on revient à les y apportant
valérie bénaïm allez on va le faire
le wiki et la sai baba bâ qui m'a plue
la ciccone la wilaya de rabat